The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so we're
going to try to finish up
oxidation reduction today.
The next unit we're heading
into is transition metals.
So, in the last class we were
talking about delta e knots of
cells, so the standard potential
of a particular
electric chemical cell.
And as we ended class last
time, you had a clicker
question, which you told me what
the reaction was at the
anode and the reaction at the
cathode for this particular
electric chemical cell.
So, now we're going to consider,
we're going to
calculate what this delta e
nought is for this cell.
So we have an equation that we
can use to calculate delta e
nought of a cell, and that is
that the delta e or the
potential of the cell, is
equal to the standard
reduction potential for the
reaction that's occurring at
the cathode, minus the standard
reduction potential
for the reaction that's
occurring at the anode.
So you told me which reaction
was occurring at the anode and
which at the cathode
last time.
So we can just go ahead and use
that information in here.
So the reaction that's occurring
at the cathode is
the copper reaction, and the
reaction and the anode is the
zinc reaction, and note here,
I have these written as
reduction potentials, because
we're going to be plugging in
the standard reduction potential
into this equation.
So, where do we get our standard
reduction potentials?
Well, your textbook has tables
of many standard reduction
potentials.
And, of course, on an exam
you would be given that
information.
And the standard reduction
potentials were measured
against the standard
hydrogen electrode.
So, now we talked last time
about what some of these
abbreviations mean.
So we can look up the values
and they're all going to be
listed as reduction reactions,
because they are standard
reduction potentials.
So all the reactions, if
you're looking for ones
written as oxidation, you'll be
out of luck, they'll all be
written as reductions.
So here, written as a reduction,
zinc plus 2, two
electrons to zinc solid,
copper plus 2 plus two
electrons to copper solid, and
you can look up those standard
reduction potentials.
And then you can plug them
in to your equation.
Again, the equation is the
standard reduction potential
for the couple at the cathode
minus the standard reduction
potential for the reaction
at the anode.
So the reaction at the cathode
is the copper reaction, and so
we have -- we put in here 0 .
3 4 0 2, and then minus, and the
zinc reduction potential's
negative, so it's minus
a minus 0 .
7 6 2 8, and then if we add
that together we get a
positive value of 1 .
1 0 3.
And so in doing these, this is a
pretty easy thing to do, but
I'm sort of emphasizing it
because a lot of people
out-clever themselves
in doing this.
They say, well, one thing's
being oxidized in this
reaction, one thing's being
reduced, so I'm looking up a
standard reduction potential,
I'm going to change the sign,
and then plug it in and
change the sign again.
And so they change the sign so
many times and they come up
with the wrong answer.
So just a hint in doing these
problems, if you always think
that the equation is asking you
for the standard reduction
potential, look that value
up and put it in.
Don't do anything fancy with
signs, just use this equation
as written, plugging in the
standard reduction potentials,
and you'll be all set and you
won't have any problems
getting it wrong.
So try not to out-clever
yourself and flip signs around
many times in doing
these problems.
All right, so we have a value,
a positive value then for our
potential for the cell.
So we can ask the question, in
this type of cell, would the
flow of electrons
be spontaneous?
What tells us if something
is spontaneous?
Delta g tells us if something
is going to be spontaneous.
And we mentioned last time
a connection between
delta g and delta e.
So, delta g tells us if
something will be spontaneous,
and we talked last time of this
equation that delta g
nought for the cell is equal to
minus n, n here being moles
of electrons times Faraday's
constant, times the delta e
nought for the cell.
So here again, we're relating
back to thermodynamics, back
to delta g, and we're thinking
about whether things are going
to be spontaneous or not.
So, if we have a positive value
for delta e nought of
the cell, what's going to be
true then for delta g?
It'll be negative, and so
will it be spontaneous?
Yes.
So, if delta e nought is
positive, delta g will be
negative, and if delta g is
negative, the reaction will,
in fact, be spontaneous.
So the answer, then, is yes.
So now let me introduce some
more terms to you.
Galvanic cell is an electric
chemical cell in which a
spontaneous chemical reaction
is used to generate an
electric current.
So on a problem, which you may
have on your problem-set and
have already looked at this,
it'll say something about for
a galvanic cell.
Well, that wasn't just kind of
random information they're
throwing out, they're telling
you that the reaction's going
to be spontaneous
in that cell.
So that will often tell you
what reaction had to be
happening at the anode, and
happening at the cathode.
Because you need to have it be
spontaneous, you need a value
for delta e nought, then
it's positive.
So, the information that it's
a galvanic cell tells you a
lot about the problem.
In contrast, we have
electrolitic cell, and in this
case, we can put in energy to
provide, to be able to drive a
non-spontaneous reaction.
So you can generate a current
to then force and
non-spontaneous reaction
to go.
So these are 2 different
kinds of cells.
So again, whether something's
spontaneous or not comes back
to our friend delta g.
So if a cell is operating
spontaneously, that means
you're going to have a delta
e nought of the cell that's
positive, which means that
the delta g of the
cell will be negative.
And we can calculate these delta
e noughts of the cell
from the standard reduction
potentials, which some nice
person measured for
us against the
standard hydrogen electrode.
And so we can look up those
values and then we can
calculate delta e nought of a
cell, we'll know something
about whether it will be a
spontaneous reaction or not.
So now let's think about the
size and the sign of standard
reduction potentials and what
they tell us about a
particular reaction.
So the meaning of the standard
reduction potential that you
can look up in your book.
So first let's think about what
happens or what would be
true if we had a large positive
delta e nought.
And that's going to mean that
the element is easy to reduce.
So let's look at an example.
At the top of your table,
you're going to see this
particular reduction with this
particular reduction potential.
So we have f two gas plus 2
electrons going to 2 f minus.
And the standard reduction
potential for this is measured
at plus 2 .
8 7 volts.
So, as written, that's the
value of the standard
reduction potential.
That's a large positive number,
so that's going to
mean that it's easy to
add electrons to f 2.
The delta g nought would
be favorable for that.
So then, you can tell me, does
that make f 2 a good oxidizing
agent or not and why?
OK, let's do 10 seconds.
Good.
Yes, it is easy to reduce.
So it's easy to add electrons,
which makes it a good
oxidizing agent.
So let's go back
to the slides.
So, a good oxidizing agent is
something that oxidizes other
elements and gets
reduced itself.
So it goes around oxidizing
things,
it's an agent of oxidation.
So something that easy to reduce
is going to be a good
oxidizing agent.
And something that's easy to
reduce is going to have a
large positive standard
reduction potential.
So, one way to sort of remember
this is for a
particular couple.
If something has a large
positive delta e nought, the
oxidized species, the oxidized
species here is the f 2, it's,
of these two things, it's
the one that's oxidized.
So the oxidized species
is very oxidizing.
So that's one way
to remember it.
Large positive delta
e nought, oxidized
species is very oxidizing.
So, here is a list that is
similar to what you would see
in the back of your book, and
we just talked about this
couple between fluoride gas and
a fluoride minus up here
with this large positive
standard reduction potential,
and as it says up
here, oxidized
form is strongly oxidizing.
Now, here we have positive
numbers, and now we start to
go to small negative numbers,
and by the time we get down
here, we have a large negative
number for the standard
reduction potential, and this
is between lithium plus and
lithium solid.
So, let's consider what would be
true down on the other end
of the table.
So a large negative delta e
nought means that the element
is hard to reduce.
So let's look at this reaction
with lithium.
So we have lithium plus
with lithium plus 1.
When you add one electron to
it, you get lithium solid.
And the standard reduction
potential for doing that
reaction is minus 3 .
0 4 5 volts.
So, that's hard to add electrons
to lithium plus 1 --
lithium plus 1 is very happy
being lithium plus 1, it
doesn't want that electron back,
and so that would be a
non-spontaneous, unfavorable
reaction.
So, is lithium plus 1 a
good oxidizing agent?
No, it's not a good oxidizing
agent, but something around
here is going to be
a good agent.
Lithium solid is a good
reducing agent.
So, lithium solid likes to
reduce other things, lithium
solid likes to be oxidized,
lithium prefers to be
lithium plus 1.
So it's very happy to be lithium
plus 1, so the solid
form is a good reducing agent.
So, if we think about what's
true at the bottom of the
table, then if we have a couple
of plus 1 to the solid,
then if you have a large
negative standard reduction
potential, the reduced species
is very reducing.
So the reduced species here is
the lithium solid, it is a
good reducing agent.
So, large negative reduced
species is reducing.
And if we go back to work table
then, up here we have
the big positive numbers.
The oxidized form of this
first couple is very
oxidizing, at the bottom you
have the large negative
numbers, and the reduced
form of that
couple is very reducing.
And you're going to be asked
questions, given different
elements in problem-sets or on
exams and saying which of
these is the better oxidizing
agent, which of these is the
better reducing agent, and be
able to compare, and you need
to think about where it is,
which are the bigger positive
numbers, bigger negative
numbers, and you can make
those comparisons, and if you
remember on the top, big
positive, oxidized form very
oxidizing, big negative,
reduced form very reducing,
you'll be all set to answer
those questions.
And some of this should be
sort of intuitive of the
things that we've talked about
already in this course.
So we think about the periodic
table for a minute, and here
are some of the potentials,
lithium is easy to oxidize,
it's a good reducing agent.
If it's lithium plus 1, then
it has a noble gas
configuration, it's
very happy there.
Whereas fluoride can get its
noble gas configuration if
it's f minus, so it's easy to
reduce and that makes it a
good oxidizing agent.
So you can think about this
in terms of it's sort of
intuitive if you think about
what you know about those
elements going into this unit.
So now, let's think about
calculating a standard
reduction potential for
this particular
electric chemical cell.
So we're given equations and
we want to calculate a
standard potential for this.
So, in doing this then, we're
going to use our standard
reduction potentials on this
table, it's a little hard to
see, so I'll go back
over there.
So now we have to figure out
if we see this equation,
what's the reaction that's
going on at the cathode?
First tell me what's happening
at the cathode -- is it an
oxidation or reduction happening
at the cathode?
The reduction is happening
at the cathode.
Now look at that equation up
there and tell me what is
being reduced -- which
element is being
reduced in that equation?
The iron is being reduced.
So we're going to write the 1/2
reaction, that's balance,
so there were two iron 3's.
And on the other side there's
two iron plus 2's, and how
many electrons am I talking
about here? two electrons.
So we have the reduction
reaction.
Then at the anode, the anode has
an oxidation going on, and
we only have one choice left
of what's being oxidized.
So, we have -- and
again balanced.
We have 2 i minus, and this is
an aqueous solution going to i
2 solid plus two electrons.
So we have now our two 1/2
reactions written out, and we
can look at the potentials for
the standard reduction
potentials, which we'll
need to calculate
the e for the cell.
So now we want to calculate
e nought for the cell, and
that's going to be
equal to the e
for the cathode reaction.
And that particular couple at
the cathode, we're looking
then at iron 3 plus going to
iron 2 plus -- that's the
reduction potential that we're
going to be looking up.
And then we also need another
standard reduction potential,
the one for the couple at the
anode, and the couple at the
anode that we're looking
up is i 2 to i minus.
So, if you can see that up
there, it's also in your
handout, then we can plug
in those values.
So, for iron, we have plus 0 .
7 7 0 volts minus plus 0 .
5 3 5 volts.
And that's going to equal 0 .
2 3 5 volts, which is
a positive number.
So what would be true about this
reaction in terms of it
being spontaneous or
non-spontaneous?
Right, so it would be
spontaneous, because you have
a positive value for delta e, so
we'd have a negative value
for delta g.
All right, so now, let's think
about what the good oxidizing
and reducing agents are here,
and let's have a clicker
question for that.
So, which is the better
oxidizing agent, iron plus 3
or i 2, and which is the better
reducing agent, i minus
or iron plus 2?
So think about that one.
All right, let's take
10 seconds.
Very good.
So the trick here is to, again,
think about these two
different potentials.
Now, unlike the example we had
before, we had a big positive
and a big negative
value, these are
both positive values.
But one of them is bigger than
the other, and so the better
oxidizing one is going to be
the one of these two, these
are both the oxidized form.
So the one with the bigger
positive number, the oxidized
species will be better at
oxidizing, and so that would
be the iron plus 3, that's the
bigger positive number.
Whereas here, when we're
considering which is the
better reducing agent, we're
looking at the two reduced
species here, and here the
thing with the smaller a
positive number, the reduced
form will be a better reducing
agent, more reducing.
So again, you can look at where
those are in the table
and the size difference
between them to
get the right answer.
So, very good.
OK, so now, I want to consider
a biological example for a
minute, and I'm going to ask a
question that we we'll then
answer at the end of class.
So in cells, things have
reduction potentials.
Vitamin B12 has a reduction
potential.
In fact, it has one of the
largest negative reduction
potentials of any biologically
occurring molecule.
And so it has to be reduced
to be active in the body.
So how can something with a very
large negative reduction
potential be reduced?
That's the question.
Why should you care?
Well, because vitamin
B12 needs to be
reduced to be active.
And the proper functioning of
enzymes, there's only actually
two that you have in humans that
require B12 -- one that
requires B12 and folic acid is
thought to be important in
preventing heart disease, birth
defects, and B12 hs
recently been linked
to mental health.
In particular, a lack of B12 has
been linked to dementia.
So, these are all pretty
significant things.
So, one thing that I think is
kind of interesting here when
they talk about heart disease,
how many people have heard of
cholesterol?
How many people have heard
of homocysteine?
Would you be surprised to know
that homocysteine is a better
indicator of whether you'll
have heart trouble than
cholesterol?
Yes.
You would think that you would
have heard of the one that was
a better link.
Well, homocysteine is actually
a better link to indicate
whether you might have heart
problems, but the thing is
that there's not a whole lot
of money to be made there,
whereas there's a lot of money
to be made in drugs that lower
cholesterol.
So you may realize, if you think
about where you get your
medical information, it's often
from commercials where
someone's trying to sell
you something.
And so if there isn't much money
to be made, say, the
treatment for a condition might
be taking vitamins,
which there's not a whole lot of
money to be made there, you
don't hear as much about it.
So, it's important to consider
the source of information
about your health, and as
scientists, you can all
evaluate information about
your health now.
All right, so vitamin B12 is
very important, you really
need vitamin B12 to be
a healthy person.
And most people at MIT are maybe
at this stage are not
that worried of heart disease.
Many of you are probably not
worried yet about having
children with birth defects,
but maybe some of you are
worried about mental recognition
of particular
facts for exams coming up, and
so you may be concerned about
B12 to keep sharp mentally.
So, where do you get vitamin
B12 and folic acid in your
diet and how is it reduced?
So let's first consider where
you get it in your diet.
So, does anyone know where you
get vitamin B12 in your diet?
I heard vegetables.
Anyone agree with vegetables?
I didn't say if anyone liked
vegetables, does anyone agree
that vitamin B12 come
from vegetables.
It doesn't.
Where does vitamin
B12 come from?
So, red meat is a good source of
vitamin B12, all meat is a
good source the vitamin B12.
Plants do not use vitamin
B12 at all.
So, people who are vegan are
in trouble in terms of how
much vitamin B12 they get, but
luckily there are vitamin
tablets that can help
take care of this.
So meat is really the best
source of vitamin B12.
So, I'm always looking for good
references to vitamin
B12, and I saw one recently.
Has anyone seen the HBO
series, True Blood.
One person.
OK, if you watch that, you will
notice that if you date a
vampire, you have to make sure
you get extra vitamin B12, and
that Sookie, of True Blood is
taking vitamin B12 tablets
just to be on the safe side.
So, vitamin B12.
What about folic acid?
Anyone know where you
get folic acid?
In the fall, what happens,
people say let's go outside
and look at the trees or look
at the pretty foliage.
Any suggestion of where
folic acid comes from?
Oh, wait a minute.
I was at a meeting once where
there was a whole lecture
about how Norwegian beer was the
best source of folic acid,
and it was, perhaps, not
coincidentally reported by
Norwegian scientists.
They would not vouch for any
other kinds, but some -- but
it does come from barleys,
vegetables,
this kind of thing.
So, here is a secret
for healthy diet.
Have some of you seen the orange
juice commercial that
says "Drink orange juice, it's
good for your heart." That's
because of this, so that
actually is potentially true.
So you get a lot of folic acid
in orange juice, and folic
acid is, in fact, good
for your heart.
So, who would have guessed,
some of the claims are
actually true.
All right, but we still have a
problem, we still need to know
how its reduced in the body.
And so we're going to come back
to that at the end of the
lecture and answer that
if we get that far.
All right, so we need to do a
couple more things first so
everyone can finish their
problem-sets, and the things
we're going to do is we're
going to look adding and
subtracting 1/2 cell reactions,
and then get to one
of my favorite things, which
is the Nernst equation.
All right.
So, some of you may have
encountered this problem on
the problem-set already.
Suppose you need you know a
standard reduction potential
and it's not given to you in
the back of the book, but
other things are given to you
in the back of the book.
Can you calculate the
thing you need
from related equations?
So suppose you really want to
know the reduction couple for
copper 2 going to copper 1.
But that's not given.
You find copper 2 with two
electrons going to copper 0,
and you find copper 0 going
to copper plus 1 with one
electron, and you'll realize
that if you combine these
equations, you'll get
the desired one.
So if you add these together,
you have copper 2 with one
electron, one electron
cancels out here.
The copper solids cancel
out and you're left
with copper plus 1.
So you add these together,
and you know the
potentials for these.
How do you get the standard
potential for the thing that
you've come up with, for
the sum of those?
So, as someone actually asked
me before class, you have to
go back to free energy, and you
do, but I'm going to drive
an equation so that you don't
have to go all the way back,
but this is, in fact, how you
do the problem, you think
about the different
free energies.
So, the new reaction, the new
delta g for that new reaction
will be equal to the delta g
knot for the reduction minus
the oxidation reaction here.
But we can substitute for
delta g this minus n,
Faraday's constant times our
reduction potential, and put
it in to this equation here.
And so we have it for the new
reaction, and then the 2
reactions that we're
adding together.
So we have Faraday's constant in
common, so that's going to
cancel out.
And we can also move n 3 to
the other side, because we
want to solve for this new e
value, this new standard
reduction potential.
And so that's going to be equal
to the number of moles
that are involved in the
reaction that's the reduction
times its reduction potential
minus the number of moles
involved in the oxidation
reaction with its reduction
potential, and then the number
of moles for the reaction that
-- this new reaction
in question.
So we can use, then, this
equation to look for a 1/2
cell reaction that is the sum
of two other reactions.
So let's go and use that
equation, then.
So here we have the known values
-- we know the couple
for copper 2 to copper 0, we
know the couple for copper 1
to copper solid, and this
is what we want to know.
So we can use this equation.
Which of these reactions is the
reduction, what value am I
going to put in here?
Which of these goes into
the reduction?
Which of these is a reduction
reaction?
Yeah.
And how many moles of electrons
are involved?
So, we put in 2 times 0 .
3 4 0 volts, and then over here
in the oxidation, there's
one electron involved, and we
put in our other potential.
So 1 times 0 .
5 2 2.
And what are the number of moles
of electrons for our
desired, final reaction?
1.
And so, then we can do the
math and come up with an
answer of 0 .
1 5 8 volts.
And so now we've just come
up with a new reduction
potential, we've calculated a
new reduction potential for
this 1/2 cell reaction
right here.
So, this equation will be given
to you on an exam and
all you need to do is
know how to use it.
So we've calculated now the
standard reduction potential
for copper 2 to copper plus 1.
So, just a little note about
when you're going to use this
and when you're going to use
the other equation that I
showed you.
So, if we're talking about a
whole electric chemical cell,
the number of moles that are
released at the anode are
going to equal the number of
moles taken up at the cathode
and be the number of
moles involved
in the overall equation.
So this equation is not
necessary, and for a full
electric chemical cell, we're
going to use the equation that
I gave you before for this delta
e nought for the cell,
so we just use this.
But if it's not a whole electric
chemical cell you're
talking about, if you're talking
about calculating a
1/2 cell potential, then you
need to use this equation.
Both of these equations will
be given to you on
sheets for the exam.
This one's for an electric
chemical cell, this one's for
calculating a 1/2
cell potential.
So again, if it's 1/2 cell
potential, you want to use
this equation.
OK, so now the Nernst
equation.
So, some of you may have
encountered in your life where
you go to turn something on
and you discover that the
battery is dead.
So, an exhausted battery is
a sign that your chemical
reaction has reached
equilibrium.
At equilibrium, you're going
to have a zero difference
potential across your
electrodes, and the battery
will be not useful to
you at that point.
So, if you -- instead of getting
annoyed next time you
have a dead battery, you can
think about all, ah, it's
finally reached equilibrium.
So, we need to think about,
then, to think about how these
cell reactions are happening,
how the potential is going to
change with the composition of
the ingredients in those
electrochemical cells.
So, we know something about
equilibrium and components of
reactions again.
So this is a nice lecture to
give coming up with a week
before the exam, because now
we're going back and reviewing
the first material on the exam
from chemical equilibrium.
So, we know that delta g is
going to change as the
components change until
equilibrium is reached.
And when equilibrium is reached
our delta g is going
to be equal to zero.
Before equilibrium is reached,
delta g will depend on the
delta g nought for the equation,
r t and the natural
log of q, where q is what?
What's q?
The reaction quotient.
So we saw this before and we're
back to using it again.
So what do we know about the
relationship between delta g
nought and delta e?
We know that delta g nought is
equal to minus n, moles of
electrons times Faraday's
constant times delta e nought.
So, we can combine some
things around.
So we can take our equation
that we saw in chemical
equilibrium and substitute in
values that are related to
standard reduction potentials.
So we can put in, for this delta
g, minus n Faraday's
constant times the delta e.
And for delta g nought, we put
in the same thing but now we
have delta e nought.
And we have r t, gas constant
times temperature times the
natural log of q, our
reaction quotient.
Now we can divide both sides
by n and Faraday's constant
and we come up with the
Nernst equation.
So the Nernst equation tells us
the potential for a cell at
any given time, at any given
component of ingredients in
the cell, any amounts of, say,
your zinc plus 2, compared to
the standard potential for that
cell, which you're going
to calculate from your standard
reduction potentials
in the table, and then you have
this term, gas constant
times temperature, number of
moles of electrons involved,
Faraday's constant, and you need
to know q, the particular
composition of the cell
at that given time.
So, just a hint in doing Nernst
equation problems, if
you're given a problem and it's
giving you concentrations
of things at a particular time,
that should be a clue
that the Nernst equation is
going to be what you're going
to want to use here.
So, let let's look
at an example.
Say we have a -- we want to
calculate the cell potential
at a given time at 25 degrees,
and we know our zinc plus 2
ions or 0 .
1 0 molar and copper
2 ions are 0 .
0 0 1 0 molar, and this is the
equation for that cell.
So we can look up, again, our
values in the table, and the
first thing we're going to do,
if we're going to use to
Nernst equation, is to calculate
the standard
potential for that particular
cell, and here are the values
from the table, and why don't
you go ahead and calculate
that for me.
All right, so let's just take
10 more seconds on that.
OK, so let's see if we can get
into the 90's pretty soon,
because we should be
able to do that for
this particular one.
All right, let's go back to
the presentation here.
So it was actually, this
was pretty easy.
I didn't actually mean for these
two things to show up,
to help you out of what the
reaction at the cathode and
the anode was, so that
was an easier
question than I had intended.
So, first you need to think
about if you're given an
equation here, what's happening
at the cathode,
what's happening at the anode.
As it's written, you can look
and see so copper plus 2 is
going to copper solid, zinc
solid's going to zinc plus 2,
so you can think about which is
the cathode reaction, which
is the anode, which has a
reduction, which has an
oxidation going on, and then
once you know which couples
you're talking about, then you
can plug in your values.
So, at the cathode, we're going
from copper plus 2 to
copper solid.
We put in our standard reduction
potential, using the
equation we have a minus, and
then the standard reduction
potential at the anode, so we
have the oxidation from zinc
solid to zinc plus 2, and we
put in this value and we
calculate the number here.
So then, we have that, we
also need to know q.
So why don't you tell
me what q is now?
OK, let's just do 10 more
seconds on this.
OK.
So here, if we go back, q is
going to be equal to products
over reactants, except things
that are solids are not are
not changing during
the equilibrium so
we leave those out.
So it's going to be
concentration of zinc plus 2
over the concentration of
copper, which gives you a
value of 1 .
0 times 10 to the 2.
So, just a review of q, if you
need help calculating q's,
we're going to have to extra
problems for the exam coming
up to be posted on Friday.
So, this'll be used
in several units.
So then you need to know n, and
then we have everything to
go back to the Nernst
equation.
So how many moles of electrons
are involved in this?
2.
Sometimes it's not so obvious,
so this can trick people, so
make sure that you pay
attention to this.
This one is a pretty
obvious one.
All right, now we have
everything that we can put in.
You calculated the standard
potential for the cell, you
calculated q, and you told
me how many moles of
electrons there are.
So we can go and put this in.
So we calculated positive 1 .
0 3 volts minus the gas
constant times the
temperature, it was at room
temperature, natural log of q.
We had two moles of electrons
and Faraday's constant here.
And now if we do the math,
this whole term
comes out to 0 .
0 5 9 2 volts, and we get our
answer, which is a positive
number there.
So, just a note about
units and constants.
Where did volts come
from here?
Well, the moles canceled out,
and the kelvin canceled out,
and we are left with joules per
Coulomb, and conveniently
for us, joules per Coulomb
is a volt.
So, all our units add up here.
And just a note about a
significant figures in doing
these problems, the Nernst
equation, boy, significant
figure fun.
If you want to make sure
you know significant
figures, here you go.
Significant figure rules for
logs, we have significant
figure rules for multiplication
and division,
and then significant figure
rules for subtraction.
So, one equation gives you
every type of significant
figure rule.
So, that can be a lot
of fun as well.
All right, but I'm going to try
to make it easier for you
on an exam and avoid
some math mistakes.
All the problems I'm going
to give you are at room
temperature.
And so, the gas constant is a
constant, temperature for
these problems is going to be
a constant, always room
temperature, Faraday's constant
is a constant.
So, all of these, I'm going to
give you the value that they
all add up to, and if you use
log instead of natural log,
there's this value as well.
So, these will be given to you
on an exam, so you'll see
these equations on the exam as
well and you can use them.
So, this is for natural log,
this is for log, so we are not
going to test your ability to
multiply room temperature
times the gas constant divided
by Faraday's constant.
So that's going to make it a
little easier in doing these
problems.
All right, so what about
at equilibrium.
What does q equal
at equilibrium?
So, q equals k at equilibrium.
What does delta g equal
at equilibrium?
Zero.
And so that means that we knew
before, from this equation,
when this is equal to zero, then
delta g knot equals minus
r t, natural log of k, so q
equals k at equilibrium.
And so we had this equation
that we used before.
We now have this equation, so
here it related delta g knot
to the equilibrium constant,
here we relate delta g nought
to delta e nought And
so, I think you
can see what's coming.
We are going to relate these two
together and come up with
an expression where are you
can calculate equilibrium
constants from standard
reduction potentials.
So, you may be asked
to do this as well.
So everything in these
units are, in fact,
related to each other.
And the only thing we have left
today, the answer to this
question about how B12 is
reduced in the body.
So, you're just going to have
to wait to find out, don't
worry you won't get heart
disease between now and
Friday, and I'll let
you know how it all
works out on Friday.